[Music]
no one here knows what is allowed but
it's quickly becoming clear what isn't
try and count how many officers get
involved here to arrest a 67 year old
activist she's affectionately known as
grandma Wong today is the anniversary of
the Tiananmen Square massacre and her
floral Memorial is not allowed Grandma
Wong's arrest is described as a move
that underscores Hong Kong's shrinking
room for freedoms it was the last
chinese-controlled territory to hold
commemorations of the 1989 Massacre
it's fairly dark it's fairly Bleak
because on one hand you've got the
world's businesses still trying to
pretend that Hong Kong is as it was we
have our own government here encouraging
people to go there and to participate in
Hong Kong and and Hong Kong spent two
million pounds on a launch campaign
called hello Hong Kong the very next day
they put 47 democracy activists on trial
Carnival
Candlelight vigils fill your stomachs
with food from across China that is
allowed
commemorating the Tiananmen massacre has
long been suppressed in China here in
Hong Kong it's become increasingly off
limits after a sweeping National
Security Law was imposed in 2020
human rights groups say the Chinese
government evades accountability for
what happened
cause of protesters were killed in a
bloody Crackdown by Chinese troops on
pro-democracy demonstrators
34 years after the massacre we still
don't know how many people died
this is where it happened in China
they've long understood what isn't
allowed on the anniversary
is just another day Sadia Chaudhary Sky
News